et notre invité politique fait fait
manuel barroso qui s'installe en direct
bonjour madame la ministre merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
ministre chargé du logement des temps
sans pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour denis
carot rien merci d'être là denis
directeur des rédactions du groupe nice
matin on va parler d' emmanuel macron
qui est en ukraine aujourd'hui qui était
en russie hier où il a rencontré
vladimir poutine pendant plusieurs
heures est ce qu'un manuel macro n'est
pas un peu en train d'instrumentaliser
la situation internationale pour ne pas
rentrer dans l'arène présidentielle
ah non je crois qu'on peut vraiment pas
dire ça emmanuel macron a pris ses
responsabilités en tant que président de
la france mais aussi à la tête de
l'union européenne pendant six mois pour
tenter une discussion qui va permettre
une désescalade dans un voilà dans un
risque de conflit important les
discussions ont été longues elles ont
été approfondis une première un premier
compte-rendu a eu lieu par conférence de
presse hier soir elles se poursuivent
aujourd'hui en ukraine et au contraire
je crois qu'on a face à nous un homme
d'état qui prend ses responsabilités et
que du coup on retarde l'échéance en dix
ans la situation internationale est trop
grave on peut pas rentrer en campagne
tout de suite ça sert aussi un petit peu
de préfet non pas du tout on a une
situation internationale significative
c'est pas nous qui l'avons créée par
ailleurs nous comme le président l'a dit
nous sommes aussi en sortie progressive
de la crise sanitaire sorti le mot peut
être un peu fort mais en tout cas avec
une crise sanitaire qui se stabilise
l'entrée en campagne aura lieu lorsque
le président voici votre à ces crises
sanitaires se termine avec la situation
internationale se terminer ça peut vous
amener loin
de la république en fonction se sont
toujours déclarés dans des délais qui
sont à peu près les délais actuels
est-ce qu'il ne prend pas en risquant
enfants prenant en faisant le choix de
se déclarer très tard je crois que les
français ils sont attachés à leurs
principales préoccupations je suppose qu
en parlera du logement dont il va en
parler vraiment sur le logement le
pouvoir d'achat la vie au quotidien
l'évolution des protocoles dans les
écoles c'est vraiment ça qui intéresse t
mais sur celles à champagney démarre pas
vraiment sans emmanuel macron ce que
vous le voyez les autres candidats
veulent débattre avec lui apportant de
figer la campagne est de priver les
français de cette campagne électorale
d'abord tous les autres candidats sont
en campagne donc on a des déclarations
plus ou moins intempestifs d'ailleurs on
y reviendra peut-être de la part de
certains candidats donc la campagne a
lieu le président de la république
déclarera sa décision quand il le jugera
utile cette campagne pour le moment elle
se joue très à droite voire à l'extrême
droite vous incarnez plutôt la gauche au
sein de territoires de progrès est ce
que cette sensibilité peut peut compter
peut peser dans cette campagne je crois
que cette sensibilité va beaucoup peser
en réalité ne serait ce que parce que
comme vous le disiez la campagne se
polarise beaucoup à l'extrême droite et
on entendait encore eric zemmour longue
d'une de ses innombrables interviews
taper sur le logement social est
stigmatisé les 11 millions de personnes
qui habitent dans le logement social je
crois que ma sensibilité
son rôle c'est de s'insurger c'est de
dire notre indignation et de montrer
qu'au contraire ce logement social c'est
une solution pour les français mais ce
que bobo sein de la majorité beaucoup
des enjeux qui intéresse les français
sont en réalité très bien portés par
cette sensibilité à laquelle
j'appartiens avec territoire de progrès
avec olivier dussopt avec jean yves le
drian et nous voyons de plus en plus de
ralliement nous avions encore un député
socialiste qui nous a rejoint il ya
quelques jours nous sommes en discussion
avec de grandes figures donc voilà
arrivés avec équipe à rejoindre c'est
trop tôt pour le dire et je vais les
laisser s'exprimer lorsqu'il le souhaite
en famenne et on parle de l'homme est en
discussions avec eux françois rebsamen
il se trouve que je les ai vus à dijon
la semaine dernière puisque je suis allé
signer avec lui le premier contrat de
relance du logement et on a beaucoup de
points communs sur beaucoup d' approche
politique et beaucoup de sensibilité
commune dit prêt à vous rejoindre
écoutez encore une fois on va les
laisser les uns les autres faire leur
déclaration quand ils le souhaiteront
allez justement va parler du logement
né de cette déclaration d impôts
effectivement eric zemmour a répété ce
week end qu'il voulait supprimer la loi
solidarité renouvellement urbain qui en
impose aux communes un quota de 20 à 25
% de logements sociaux
il a expliqué je cite elle transformera
la la france sans citer je ne veux pas
de kebabs dans tous les villages de de
france il a confirmé il a expliqué hier
que les hlm sont des terres
d'islamisation du du pays que vous
inspirent ces propos de l'indignation et
de la colère en réalité parce que
derrière ces propos qui sont des propos
tribune il stigmatise on mise 11
millions de personnes qui habitent dans
des hlm est en fait vous savez il a dit
il a fait un lapsus sur l'une des
chaînes il ya quelques jours il a dit je
vois ce que je crois et en fait c'est ça
il ne il voit tout à l'aune d'un prisme
qui est un prisme sur lequel il suffit
de blâmer les étrangers y compris
d'ailleurs des personnes qui en réalité
sont françaises française depuis
plusieurs générations pour expliquer
tous les maux du pays je crois qu'à un
moment il faut lui dire que ça suffit
ils empêchent moi je me devais des fonds
du logement social depuis ma prise de
fonction en tant que ministre du
logement en juillet 2020 je me suis
battu pour soutenir le logement social
nous avons proposé à l'assemblée et au
sénat de rendre la loi sru permanente ça
a été voté par la droite et par la
gauche est évidemment par la majorité
présidentielle
nous avons trouvé un consensus il ya une
cmp conclusive et cette loi sru va
devenir permanente parce qu'on a besoin
de logements pour les classes moyennes
partout où il ya besoin de logement tout
court autant est ce que est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas l'adapter on voit les
difficultés et on connaît bien cette
situation sur sur la côte d'azur avec
des communes qui n'ont pas le foncier
nécessaire et qui du coup paye des payes
des amendes est-ce qu'il ya pas d'autres
voies d'autres solutions justement tout
ce travail que nous avons fait sur la
loi sru pour le texte qui est passée là
il ya quelques semaines la loi
décentralisation 3ds nous a permis aussi
de renforcer la contractualisation entre
l'état et les maires et c'est un travail
que nous avons fait y compris avec la mf
y compris avec son président que vous
connaissez de vie david lisnard pour
essayer de trouver une manière de garder
une ambition forte grâce à la loi sru on
a construit à peu près la moitié des
logements sociaux qui ont été construits
d'escompté pas faire davantage confiance
au maire justement la nouvelle version
prévoit un contrat de mixité sociale
signée entre le maire et le préfet qui
permet d'adapter la trajectoire
aujourd'hui la trajectoire de
construction de logements sociaux et les
mécaniques c'est une formule de calcul
demain ça pourra être adapté dans cette
contractualisation entre les maires et
les préfets mais il faut voir à quel
point le logement des classes moyennes
est un sujet c'est vrai pour le logement
social
nous avons besoin d'autres formes de
logement pour les classes moyennes le
locatif dit intermédiaire à des prix
entre le logement social et les prix du
marché et c'est vrai aussi pour
l'accession sociale à la propriété
nous avons besoin de continuer à
permettre aux ménages d'acheter leur
leur maison leur résidence principale ou
leur appartement car juste leurs valises
et valérie pécresse elle a dit qu' elle
soit desserré l'étau de cette loi srl
après de présenter sa proposition le
logement social
4 les aides de la région ile-de-france
réduit 10 fois et qu'il faut desserrer
l'étau pour y intégrer toutes les formes
de logements intermédiaires ainsi que
l'accession sociale à la propriété la
warner fois que quelqu'un a proposé de
mettre l'accession à la propriété dans
les quotas de la loi sru dans le calcul
de la loi sru de l'abbé pierre s'est
déplacé à l'assemblée nationale pour
dire son indignation sur ce sujet et
pour rappeler que le logement social
était une priorité c'était sous la
mandature sarkozy donc non je ne suis
pas favorable à ces sites est en
revanche dit on a aussi besoin de
soutenir l'accession sociale à la
propriété
c'est vrai on le fait avec le prêt à
taux zéro on le fait avec ce qu'on
appelle le bail réel solidaire qui
permet d'acheter les murs et pas le
terrain et j'étais voyez j'étais à
annemasse hier à côté d'annemasse dans
une commune qui s'appelle ans billy très
exactement donc en haute savoie à côté
de genève la première opération by réel
solidaire va sortir de l'accession à la
propriété qui permet d'acheter à peu
près à la moitié du prix du marché et
vous savez que dans la partie de haute
savoie qui est tout proche de genève les
prix sont extrêmement élevés parce
qu'évidemment il la pression des
frontaliers de ceux qui ont des salaires
suisses et qui du coup ont un meilleur
pouvoir d'achat que ceux qui sont payés
en euros donc je crois vraiment que ce
type de nouveaux outils qui datent
d'ailleurs de la mandature précédente
est vraiment utile on est en train de
les développer on en avait quelques
centaines on va passer à plusieurs
milliers j'espère plusieurs dizaines de
millions va parler logement sur une
petite parenthèse sur les propos d'eric
zemmour puisqu'on a appris hier que
l'union sociale pour l'habitat allait
porter plainte suite aux propos d'eric
zemmour vous soutenez cette plainte en
tout cas je soutiens leur indignation
puisque je pense que c'est vraiment et
un moment où il faut arrêter de dire
n'importe quoi et stigmatiser les
français donc on va voir comment cette
relecture évolué mais pas forcément la
plante pas forcément la bonne méthode
pour vous vos objectifs en termes de
logement social n'ont pas été tenues
alors certes la crise sanitaire et est
passée par là mais comment faire en
sorte de passer la vitesse supérieure de
construire de construire davantage la
fondation abbé pierre a souligné la
faiblesse du quinquennat en la matière
alors d'abord nos objectifs de
construction tout court en réalité on
était très largement tenu puisque on a
construit un peu plus de 2,2 millions de
logements en cinq ans c'est à dire plus
que dans le quinquennat précédent et 470
milles permis de construire l'année
dernière donc mais il reste struction
2,2 millions de français qui sont en
attendant en construction tout court
les choses se sont bien établis malgré
évidemment la crise sanitaire et toutes
les interruptions de l'année 2020 sur le
logement social c'est vrai que nous ne
sommes pas au rendez vous nous espérions
120000 agrément de logements sociaux
cette année on en fera en réalité 105000
et c'est pas assez on sait qu'on a
besoin de plus vous l'avez dit plus de
deux millions de personnes sont en
attente d'un logement social je crois
que c'est combien si vous faites un
prochain quinquennat notre objectif
l'année dernière c'était 120000
l'objectif cette année ses 125 milles
donc même si nous n'y sommes pas nous
gardons des objectifs ambitieux pour
cela il faut mobiliser les élus d'abord
parce que ce sont eux qui signe les
permis de construire est dit et qui à
gré les bailleurs sociaux en soutenant
leurs efforts de construction le foncier
public c'est très souvent une question
de foncier c'est à dire où est ce qu'on
va pouvoir construire est évidemment que
toutes les campagnes stigmatise quand
les locataires de logement social ça
n'aide pas parce qu'on on attise la peur
des français et la peur des riverains
donc redire que le logement social scene
logement des classes moyennes c'est en
fait un discours absolument essentiel et
s'il ya besoin de moyens supplémentaires
on ne s'interdit pas d'en remettre on
repart dans des contrats de relance du
logement donc des contrats ou encore une
fois pour faire confiance aux élus entre
l'état et les maires ou les présidents
d'intercommunalités à annemasse pareil
ils sont en train d'en regarder un
j'étais aussi dans le pays de gex hier
dans l'ain ils sont aussi en train d'y
travailler et si c'est une question de
moyens je pense qu'on saura les trouver
mais je pense que c'est d'abord une
question d'état d'esprit concernant
toujours le logement social le problème
c'est aussi l'absence de mixité comment
faire en sorte au-delà du nombre de
constructions de logements sociaux de
favoriser d'encourager davantage la
mixité sociale vous voyez c'est tout le
paradoxe de notre discussion puisque
cette fameuse loi sru dont on parle
depuis et depuis début de cet échange
c'est la loi qui dit qu'il faut faire
des logements sociaux partout dans
toutes les communes dans lesquelles il
ya de la tension sur le logement
si cette loi ne s'applique pas alors on
fait du logement social là où les maires
ont envie d'en faire est pas là où ils
sont plus réticents et dans ce cas là du
coup on accroît la concentration mais
encore une fois le logement social 70%
des français ils sont éligibles donc ça
n'est pas que le logement des personnes
les plus en difficulté c'est aussi le
logement des classes moyennes c'est
aussi une question d'attribution dans
ces demandeurs qui va pouvoir avoir
accès à un logement social et dans la
loi 3ds nous avons rendu prioritaire les
travailleurs clé et ça c'est très
important et c'est une discussion que
j'ai très souvent avec les élus je les
ai eus hier avec les maires du pays de
gex c'est important de dire les les
fonctionnaires hospitaliers les
les boulangers les personnes qui
travaillent dans les commerces
alimentaires dans les grandes surfaces
etc tous ceux qui font vivre la vie le
vivre ensemble au quotidien cela doivent
aussi être prioritaire dans le logement
social donc on l'a rendue possible dans
la loi 3ds dire les personnes qui sont
indispensables au bon fonctionnement de
la vie en société à un endroit donné
doivent pouvoir habiter pas trop loin de
la wii travail le logement ce sont aussi
les aides emmanuel macron a estimé la
semaine dernière que le système des
aides personnalisées au logement était
imparfait qu'il faudrait pouvoir je cite
mieux accompagner celles et ceux qui
sont en difficulté
il faut aller vers une réforme en
profondeur des apl en fait le président
de la république avait soutenu au début
du quinquennat avant la crise sanitaire
le projet d'un rapprochement des
différentes prestations sociales qui
s'appelle revenu universel d'activité et
qui consiste à dire toutes ces grandes z
elles ont toutes des mécanismes
différents on calcule pas les ressources
de la même manière les modalités de
versement sont pas les mêmes et du coup
quand elles s'articulent les unes avec
les autres elles s'articulent mal et a
des trous dans la raquette et donc des
gens qui sont finalement mal protégé est
donc cette idée revient je pense qu'elle
est très importante potentiellement pour
la suite avec l'idée de dire il faut
être sûr que toutes ces aides
s'harmonisent bien et qu'on soutient au
maximum tous ceux qui en ont besoin donc
c'est pas les apl en tant que tel c'est
plutôt les appels dans l'environnement
des prestations sociales et cette
réforme elle doit pouvoir faire plus de
gagnants elle doit permettre de limiter
le non recours est donc ce sera une
réforme dans laquelle on investit sur
les appels justin vampiriser mois marine
le pen ne veulent appliquer la
préférence nationale sur ces êtres
qu'est ce que vous en pensez moi je suis
pas favorable du tout les personnes qui
sont en situation régulière sur le
territoire français qui travaillent qui
payent des impôts des cotisations
sociales ont le droit à la protection
sociale c'est la base de notre
solidarité cela le logement plus
généralement au delà du logement social
puisque valérie pécresse était hier dans
votre département du val de marne pour
présenter dans son programme sur le
logement elle dit qu'elle promet si elle
est élue de fixer un objectif de 500
milles construction de logements par an
pour bâtir une france de pro estaires
dit elle et elle dénonce le mépris des
manuels macron vis-à-vis de la propriété
privée que leur répondez vous d'abord on
à 470 milles permis de construire donc
effectivement on est dans cette
fourchette autour de 500 milles qui est
l'objectif que nous nous sommes déjà
fixé d'ailleurs moi quand je regarde
tout ce qu'a proposé valérie pécresse
hier on a vraiment l'impression que
c'est la somme de toutes les mesures que
le ministère du logement a mis en place
dans les quelques dernières années le
prêt à taux zéro il existe partout en
france la lutte contre les squats en 48
heures on a fait voter une loi au début
de l'année on en a beaucoup parlé quant
à la propriété moi je suis pour le
parcours résidentiel c'est à dire
permettre à tous ceux qui le souhaitent
de devenir propriétaire on a à peu près
58% de propriétaires en france permettre
aussi à ceux qui commencent par la
location de pouvoir le faire dans de
bonnes conditions je pense aux jeunes
par exemple on a besoin de continuer à
construire du logement pour les jeunes
par ailleurs la france des propriétaires
c'était le grand slogan du quinquennat
sarkozy au début du quinquennat avec
madame boutin ministre du logement on a
commencé le quinquennat à 57 % de
propriétaires et on a fini à 58% de
propriétaires
donc en réalité on a en france de marché
un marché des propriétaires il faut
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
pouvoir accéder à la propriété en ce
moment les taux d'intérêt sont plutôt
bas donc on est dans une période plutôt
favorable pour ça mais il faut aussi
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
pouvoir accès pouvoir pardon avoir accès
à un logement locatif donc il faut
vraiment travailler sur ces messieurs je
vous résume donc valérie pécresse chose
dans votre programme et fait des
premiers des choses que l on est au
programme soit de nicolas sarkozy 10 à
15 ans soit de ce qu'on a fait récemment
et sur un mot sur ce qu'elle a qualifié
d' absurdité absurdité dans un
territoire rural la règle de 0
artificialisation des sols est ce que la
nappe a raison il faudrait savoir si
elle porte des préoccupations
écologiques oui ou non plus qu'elle nous
dit que lé très écologiste le zéro net
artificialisation ça ne veut pas dire on
arrête partout de construire y compris
en ruralité ça veut dire collectivement
on se donne un objectif d'essayer de
consommer un peu moins de terres
naturelles et agricoles on consomme
l'équivalent d'un département trois cent
mille hectares tous les dix ans on s'est
dit que dans les dix prochaines années
on essaierait de consommer qu'un demi
départements c'est-à-dire cent cinquante
mille hectares c'est déjà pas mal et
ensuite toujours pareil on fait
confiance aux élus locaux pour
travailler à l'échelle intercommunale
pour définir les besoins et voir comment
on fait cette trajectoire collectivement
mais vous savez la question de
l'étalement urbain c'est une question
écologique et c'est aussi une question
sociale parce que plus vous êtes loin du
premier commerce plus vous êtes loin de
l'école plus vous êtes loin de l'endroit
où vous travaillez plus forcément vous
dépendez de la voiture lorsque il n'y a
pas suffisamment d'habitants pour avoir
des transports en commun qu'ils soient
suffisamment efficace donc la lutte
contre l'étalement urbain c'est aussi
une réponse à la lutte contre la vie
chère c'est aussi une réponse aux
besoins de services publics de proximité
c'est aussi une réponse aux besoins du
lien social je vois que vous êtes assez
critique c'est le jeu vous me direz en
campagne avec les programmes des
adversaires des manuels mâcon j'imagine
que vous travaillez sur le programme
logement d'emmanuelle bien suivi
l'action les grandes lignes écoutez on
va attendre encore une fois que le
président de la république
se déclare lorsqu il le souhaitera mais
on travaille à la fois sur la base de ce
que nous avons fait et puis voilà allez
probablement un cran plus loin on
parlait de la réforme des aides le
soutien à la construction le soutien au
logement social on va aller un cran plus
loin sur nos grands axes il faut aller
plus loin en termes d'encadrement des
loyers on voit très bien que se loger
coûte de plus en plus cher moi je suis
plutôt favorable à l'encadrement des
loyers comme l'une des mesures qui
permettent l'accès à un logement
abordable pour tous il n'y a pas que ça
parce que on a lancé un bel avantage
fiscal qui s'appelle loc avantage lancé
au début de cette année qui permet de
louer moins cher avec une réduction
d'impôts ça aussi je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudra développer
par la suite l'encadrement des loyers
fait partie des outils qui sont
potentiellement utiles j'ai soutenu la
prolongation de l'expérimentation et
surtout la réouverture on a des communes
ou des communautés de communes qui
souhaitent candidate et je pense par
exemple aux communes du pays basque la
communauté d'agglomération du pays
basque est motivé pour candidater je
pense qu'il ya des endroits dans
lesquels c'est nécessaire un mot sur
nice un mot sur alice le bailleur social
côte d'azur habitat a lancé 72 procédure
d'expulsion à l'encontre de famille qui
compte des délinquants est ce que il
faut aller dans cette voie là c'est une
mesure qui se fait en accord avec le
avec la justice avec le parquet de nice
moi j'y suis favorable je pense qu'à un
moment quand vous avez une ou deux
familles aux situations où personne
d'ailleurs c'est rarement les familles
qui crée des difficultés très très
importante dans une résidence la justice
doit agir donc travaillé avec la justice
évidemment tout ceci doit se faire dans
une procédure graduée c'est à dire il
faut commencer par du dialogue et de la
médiation mais si ça ne suffit pas
travailler avec la justice on doit aussi
la tranquillité à tous les résidences à
rejoindre une des propositions d'eric
zemmour écouter eric zemmour il veut
supprimer le logement social donc il en
est pas à faire dans la dentelle et
parler de médiation d'abord donc non je
crois qu'il ya pas beaucoup de sujets
sur lesquels je suis d'accord avec eric
zemmour à moi sur ma prime rénové
avant qu'elle aide de l'état pour la
transition énergétique d'un logement est
ce que là dessus vous allez aller plus
loin est ce qu'il ya d'autres mesures en
préparation alors en fait on travaille
sur un triptyque ma prime rénove c'est
la prestation france rénove ce sont les
guichets où on peut aller se renseigner
et mon accompagnateur rénove c'est la
personne qui va pouvoir vraiment vous
accompagner techniquement pour faire des
travaux et ça ça monte en puissance ma
prime rénove ça marche très très bien on
va fêter dans peu de temps le
millionième dossiers déposés il faut
d'abord consolider les aides peut-être
les renforcer encore un peu pour qu'elle
soit encore plus avantageuses donc on a
toujours nous des idées pour améliorer
les aides france rénove se sont donné
on a stabilisé le barème de la prime
rénove pour 2022 donc après c'est plutôt
pour la suite france rénovons la lancée
au 1er janvier 2022 c'est aussi un beau
progrès parce que c'est une marque qui
unifie des guichets avant on était tous
un peu perdu il ya aussi besoin de plus
de conseillers de plus de guichets donc
ça aussi c'est à vocation à s'étendre et
mon accompagnateur rénoverons note en
train de travailler le texte
d'application de la loi climat et
résilience pour trouver la bonne manière
d'agréer les accompagnateurs et là aussi
les faire monter en puissance donc ce
triptyque accompagnement aide guichet
c'est la base de cette politique je
pense que c'est une base très solide et
après à partir de cette base on peut
tout améliorée et lancer un prêt rénove
notamment oui vous avez raison le
quatrième morceau vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est ce qu'on appelle le prêt
avance rénovation qui permet de financer
le reste à charge en ne payant en ne
remboursant le prêt qu'au moment où on
revend le bien et ça c'était vraiment
une demande à la fois des associations
et de tous les acteurs ça vient d'être
lancée publicité banque postale et
crédit mutuel qui ont accepté de
distribuer ce prêt et je ferai la
publicité de toutes les autres banques
qui acceptent de le distribuer allez on
a commencé en parlant d'élection
présidentielle une dernière question
pour terminer ce que vous serez
candidate aux législatives
écoutez pour l'instant on est tous
mobilisés sur la présidentielle les
investitures des législatives ne sont
pas faites et vous savez quel
et là moi j'ai envie de continuer j'ai
envie de m'engager je suis déjà
conseillère régionale en ile de france
et l'ue dans le val de marne donc j'ai
envie de défendre mon territoire donc
vous serez candidate à l'investiture
dans le val de marne j'imagine j'ai
juste envie de défendre mon territoire
ya plein de manières de le faire merci
beaucoup emmanuelle wargon
[Musique]